LEE BOONSTRA: Hi, guys.
Whoop.
Welcome.
My name is Lee Boonstra.
I work as a customer
engineer for Google.
And that means that I help
in the pre-sales process,
customers, with creating
prototypes or answering
questions about all
our Google products.
And I have a background
in software development.
So Google asked
me like, hey, Lee,
do you want to give a talk
about G Suite this year?
I said, yes, but I like
to give a technical talk.
I love to talk about how you
can extend on top of G Suite,
whether it's in your
own applications
or whether you want to write
code on top of G Suite,
because that is
basically the idea on how
if you want to extend on
it, there are two ways.
You can take the
Apps Script approach.
That means, like, I stay
within the Google domain
but in a G Suite domain.
And I write my own
code on top of G Suite.
You can do that
through Apps Script.
The other approach, that
is through Google APIs.
That is, I have my
own application,
and I host it somewhere.
But I want to bring my
data inside of my apps.
I want to get everything
from G Suite inside
of my own applications, so to
leverage the power of G Suite.
So you probably would take
one of these approaches.
I'm curious how many developers
are here in the room?
A few?
Or how many people
read code once before?
Yes, a little bit more, right?
For the people
that are not really
into coding but they have great
ideas on building applications,
I will also cover
apps, App Maker--
that is our visual
design editor--
how you quickly can create
applications, basically,
by dragging and dropping,
so with no code.
And that's going to be
interesting as well.
But let's talk about
Apps Script first.
What is Apps Script?
Apps Script, it's
basically JavaScript,
but it runs on a
server, serverless.
That doesn't mean that
there are no servers.
No, there are servers
arranged somewhere.
But Google all
takes care of that.
And we just write JavaScript
code as if it was in a browser.
But just keep in mind, it runs
somewhere on a Google server.
And together with that, it
also has all these nice APIs,
these Google APIs,
and services that
are all available within
your Apps Script environment.
And with that, you can create
your own add-ons or extensions
or themes, and the
big advantage here
is that once you do that
through Apps Script,
you no longer need
to deal with OAuth.
That has all been
taken care of you.
[? In ?] OAuth, that
is a way how you
can secure your applications.
The developers here
probably will understand,
like to set that up,
that could be difficult.
But this has all been arranged
in the environment from G
Suite.
So that is nice.
And with that, you also
get a lot of other tools,
like monitoring
tools and logging.
And then once you have
your add-on finished,
you can drop it in a marketplace
or in the Chrome Web Store,
or you can have it
internally being shared.
There are, in general, four
different entry points.
And if you want to write Apps
Script code, where would you
start?
And I think the most common
one that will be like,
I have in a document
or sheet and I
want to write scripts for
that particular document
or particular sheet.
So there is like a
relation between your code
and that sheet.
We call that
container-bound script.
So it's one document
or one sheet,
together bundled with your code.
And to talk to that code,
what you would first
do in your code, you would
say, like, documentApp
and then getActiveDocument
or getActiveSpreadsheet.
So you have a reference to that
active tab or active sheet.
And then you can
start coding on it.
You will write some triggers.
You say, like, every time
when I open this document,
I execute this piece
of code, or every time
I edit this document, I run some
secret code in the background.
That's how you have
to set that up.
Now, the other
entry point it will
be like it's not bound to a
particular document or sheet.
In this case, you
would create like you
would create a normal
web application,
but with Apps Script.
So you would go to
script.google.com,
or you go to your Google Drive.
And from there, you open the
Apps Script native editor.
And then you start coding
your scripts over there.
And typically what people do
is, then, when you execute,
when you run such
a piece of code,
then they show a file picker.
And the user can select
the sheet or document
that they need, and then you
can start executing the code.
That way it's more reusable.
Now, there's another entry
point that is more like AdWords.
It's like in case you're
doing stuff with advertising.
You can also code App Script
code, so JavaScript code which
runs on the server, but
it's particular for AdWord.
And the last one, although
App Maker, in general, you
don't necessarily need to code,
you could code if you want.
And there you have the choice
between normal JavaScript
code or also Apps Script.
And then again, it
runs on the server.
We will talk about this later.
So how would I write
Apps Script code?
I'll show you, like, a simple
demo on how you could do that.
But first, as a
developer, what I would do
is I would read the manual.
So I go to the docs
page from Google.
There they really
explain it pretty well,
like, all the APIs
methods that are available
and that you can start using.
If it's for a
container-bound script,
or if it's for your
own web applications,
it's all available there.
And that's definitely
the starting point
where you would start.
In this case, I went
to the Google Drive.
I start opening my native
editor, Google Apps Script.
I could also
[INAUDIBLE] @google.com.
And what I'm going to
create in this example
is a kind of conference
application, where speakers
can upload their presentation.
And every time when a
presentation was uploaded,
I will get an email to ask me if
I can approve the presentations
and can read through it.
I think this is a very
simple application,
but a use case that I
think everybody could,
yeah, could create.
So what you would
do here in this case
is you would go to
their Google Drive.
You will create a folder.
And you need to
share that folder,
because then all the
other speakers can upload
their presentation in there.
And when you do
that, you get an ID.
And that is an ID
that you need to copy,
because this is the idea we
will refer to in our code.
So in our native editor,
we will create a variable
called Slides Folder ID.
And then I paste the code
that I just copied in there.
And then I start
writing JavaScript code.
It's very easy.
In this case, I create
a variable folder,
and I say, like, drive
application, get folder by ID.
And I take the ID
that just copied.
The next thing is I want to
retrieve all the files that
are in that folder.
So I can do that
with folder.getFiles.
And the next thing on line
6, what I'm doing here
is I create a kind of store.
So what I want to do
is I want to create
some kind of persistence
layer here, so simple storage
that every time, next week,
if I open this script,
that it still has some way of
storing which files are new
and which files are old.
So it's a kind of
key value store.
It's very simple.
So that's what
I'm creating here.
The next thing is I create
a variable, new files.
This is just for flagging
if the file is new.
And then I will loop through
all the files, the file iterator
that I created before.
And I check if the file is new.
And if the file is new,
then I'm going to add it
to the new files array.
So then I can do
something with that later.
And I will also add it
to the persistence layer
so that next week when I run
this script, then the new file
won't show up again.
And the last piece of
the code, in this case,
I check, like, oh, are
there any new files?
Well, yes there are.
OK, I'm going to lock them.
I'm using basic locking here.
And I'll send an email.
And the email, that's done
through the email API.
So I can say gmailapp.sendEmail.
What am I sending?
I sent an email to the
active user, which is me.
And I retrieve file
getName and file getURL.
So that is what I
push in the email.
And then I can start testing it.
So I would press the
Play button here.
At that moment, I will
probably see a log message.
So you can go to your basic
logging, so view logs.
And then you would
see a log message
like what you see
on the top screen.
But if you want to
have it more advanced,
it is possible to
use Stackdriver here.
And then you would
use console.log.
And then once it
is in Stackdriver,
you have much nicer, richer
stack traces and better
logging.
So that's an option for you.
This is the email, how
it would look like when
I retrieve that email.
Now, that was just a test.
How can I bring
that to production?
Well, I need to set up some
project triggers in this case.
That means, like, I'm
going to schedule it,
that every time it will run.
When I create my first onProject
triggers there aren't any.
So I need to go
through this process.
This also means that I
need to be authenticated.
I need to authorize
myself that I
am allowed to open the drive
box and also the email.
So I [INAUDIBLE]
the permissions.
You get like a nice
all-out pop-up.
And you allow that pop up.
And you can see also I need
read, send, and deleted access
for Gmail.
That doesn't necessarily need
to be the case, because I'm only
sending an email.
But definitely for if
you want to read email
from your Gmail account, then
you need to approve on that.
And I also need to give
access to do the drive.
I then accept the trigger.
And in this case, I create a
time trigger for five minutes.
And every five minutes it
starts running the script.
And then it sees if
there are new files in,
and sends me an email
if there are any.
This all runs on
the Google server.
There are a couple of things
on the roadmap for Apps Script
and add-ons in general.
And one of these things
is Gmail add-ons,
which is something I like
because now we can probably
create kind of
templates in Gmail
that you can automatically
send reports or so.
Slides will also
get add-on feature.
I use a lot of slides, as I do
a lot of these kind of talks.
So I'm very happy with that.
That is actually an
early access program.
So if you want, you
can try this out.
Just register for that.
And also mobile
add-ons, so if you
create Apps Script
for docs or sheets,
then it will also work
on your mobile phone.
That works through your
mobile phone via the browser
but on native also on Android.
Now let's take a look into
the second approach that
will be the Google APIs.
Google supports many, many
languages, if not all,
almost all of the popular ones.
Think about node.js or
JavaScript, Java.net, Ruby,
also for mobile, Go language.
Google has all client SDKs
for all these languages.
And you can just start
downloading such an SDK
and then implement that in
your own web application.
So in this case, what
we're going to do
is we're going to integrate G
Suite in our own applications.
Through such an API,
such as client SDK,
you get all the end points.
And with that you can retrieve
access to the Google Drive
or to your sheets.
So let me show you
an example of that.
I created a simple application
myself the other week,
where I wanted to create--
for my Google Home,
I wanted to make sure
that the Google Home would
read up all my emails.
And the way how I wanted to do
that is by putting all my email
headers in a sheet and
then asked Google Home
to read up the sheet.
So I created that
with node.js because I
am a JavaScript developer.
So I went to NPM.
I downloaded the package.
The next thing is in my Google
Cloud, I go to Gmail API,
and I need to enable APIs.
So every API that
you want to use,
you need to make sure
that you first enable it.
And at that moment,
you can also monitor it
and see the amount of users that
has been used through your API.
And you can secure
it, so not secretly.
Other people can
start using the API.
So it's really all secure within
the-- yeah, with the OAuth
from Google.
You set up your credentials.
What I did is I created a JSON
file, a JSON credentials key.
Service account we call that.
And I put that in
my folder structure.
And a service account
contains all the information
of connecting to my account.
I need to set that up
and whitelist that.
Then I need to start
looking into OAuth2.
That can be tricky,
but luckily the SDKs,
they have support for that.
So you can start using the
predefined code from Google.
And that is what I
did in this case.
First, I generated the URL.
The SDK did that for me.
With that URL, I can log
into my own Google account.
So at that moment, it
knows that it's about me
and that I give access to
certain files or folders.
I get redirected to a different
page, and I get a new code.
And with that code I create an
[? alternate ?] object, which
will be a [INAUDIBLE] token.
And what I did is I saved
that in my folder structure
so that the next
time I don't need
to go through this whole process
again when I'm on localhost.
Now then the code, code is
not so difficult either.
I started with
implementing the packages.
So I say, I require
the Google APIs
and I require the Google
[INAUDIBLE] library.
So I don't need to do all
the OAuth stuff myself.
I can just copy-paste
that, which
is to authorize the get
new token and the store
token functions.
I need to define scopes.
Now, in this case, I want
to get access to Gmail.
So I set the scope for that.
And I also created
a folder where
I-- or I point to the folder
where I saved the service
token on my hard drive.
So then node.js can
figure that out.
And this is the actual
code that I wrote myself.
By looking into
the documentations,
I said gmail.users
messages list.
So I want to retrieve all the
emails that are in my inbox.
And in this case,
I query on unread.
So these are new messages that
are coming in in my email box.
If it went wrong, because
this is a callback what
you see here, if
it went wrong, it
shows me an error
message in Stackdriver.
If it went fine, then
it gets into here.
And then I save the
emails in variable emails.
This will be an array with IDs.
You probably choose
such an ID want
to retrieve the body of
the email and the subject.
So then you would say
gmail.users.message.get.
And then you query on the
ID that you just retrieved.
And at that moment, then
you have all the emails.
Then I would put it in my--
I would make another call
to access my spreadsheet
and save it in there.
Now, there are
many APIs like this
that you can start
using for Google Drive,
for Calendar,
Gmail, you name it.
Almost every Google
project has an own API
that you can start using
and playing around with.
Definitely, if
you're a developer,
I would definitely look into it.
Because Google made so
much nice things for you,
that you can very
easily just start using.
So pretty awesome.
And the next thing that I
like to look into, that is
App Maker, and
maybe you've seen it
in the keynote earlier today.
This is our visual
drag-and-drop design editor.
You can create applications,
but you don't necessarily
need to code.
And I will show you
that also in my demo.
I will show a to-do
application that I created in
within five minutes
with no coding,
just dragging and dropping.
So it's powerful apps
for your business.
The key benefits in this
case is that you can
create applications very fast.
It's all integrated
within G Suite,
so you can make use of all the
G Suite APIs, the Google APIs.
You can also make use of
the Google Cloud Platform
components.
So for example, if you want to
store your data in the Cloud
SQL, yeah, you can easily
just connect to that
and set that up.
Data binding-- so once you have
your data in your application,
you can very easily just
bind it to a widget,
and you will see it on the page.
And the last thing, everything
is compliant and secure.
Because it's in the Google
domain, it's all secure,
and nobody else can get there.
That also means
that you're building
applications for a domain and
not really for an app store.
Yeah, this answers the question
that a lot of companies
and developers had,
where enterprises
want to create applications.
Even at Google, we have
lots of business problems
that we want to solve.
And, yeah, of course, you can
ask a developer to code it,
and then it will
take maybe months.
But how nice would it be if
you can just create it yourself
very easily by prototyping it?
Or you can create a production
version within a few days.
Think about dashboards,
asset trackers, HR program,
stuff like that.
This is very, very
essential, and everybody
could start using it.
It's a [? SaaS ?] application.
That runs in your browser.
And everybody with a G
Suite business account
can easily just log in and
start playing around with it.
It's based on [INAUDIBLE]
standards, so HTML, JavaScript,
CSS.
It also works nice on mobile.
So you get like the Material
Design look and feel.
That runs nice on the tablet,
runs also nice on the desktop.
Yeah, you don't need to
be a software developer,
in this case.
So instead of
talking about it, let
me show you a demo
that I created on how
you can create an application.
It's a semi-live
demo, I have to say,
because I recorded it because
I was afraid, like, what
if we were a bit over time,
then it's probably better
if I just show a video.
So I will go through the video
with you, and I will stop,
pause it.
What you see here is the App
Maker, the default screen.
You start by setting
up a project.
And then the first thing
that you typically would do
is you would create a model.
And a model that
is like describing
an entity, and an entity,
for example, could be a car.
A car has a brand.
A car has a color.
It has a number of
wheels, all properties
from a [? certain ?] type
that you need to define.
And then you bind it to some
data source, some database,
to retrieve all that data.
And that is what we're
going to do here.
By default, it will select
the Google Drive table.
That means that the
persistence layer
will be in the Google Drive.
We're going to save all
the data in Google Drive.
But there are other ways
which you could do as well.
For example, you could
store it in Cloud SQL
or you could store
it in a directory.
Now, this all, you
can just select it.
In this case, I'm just
creating my own model.
And I want to save it
in the Google Drive.
I'm not taking anything
difficult here.
And this will be a
to-do application.
So I give the model
name the name Tasks.
And I'm going to create some
fields for the task model.
If I want, I could
retrieve fields.
[INAUDIBLE] and maybe
a database export.
And you want to
retrieve all the fields.
Or what I'm doing here,
I'm creating them manually.
So I create a field task name.
And task name will be a string.
And that will be to save
the name of the task.
The next thing
that I will do is I
will create a field
called Task Date to mark
when the task was created.
That will be of the type Date.
I can just select that.
And the last one
that I will do is
I will create a field
called Completed, which
will be a Boolean type to flag
if I completed the task, yes
or no, true or false.
All right, now I'm
done with the model.
I could connect, at this
point, to databases and stuff.
But I'm not going to do it.
I'm just going to create
a very simple application.
I create some pages here.
For my application,
I need two pages.
One is the main screen.
That will take in
all the components.
And then I will create a second
page, which is the Add screen.
That will be a pop-up with
a floating form, where
I can create new to-dos.
And then it will be
shown on the main screen.
So that is what I'm doing here.
I create a second page.
And I will give it the name Add.
There you go.
It's important how you name
it, because this is also
where you reference it later.
This is how App
Maker will know that.
OK, what you see
me doing here is I
clicked on the Widgets button.
And I can select a widget.
So I can choose from Forms
or Tables or Buttons.
All types of
components are there.
And in this case, I selected
the Table component.
And what it does,
it automatically
recognized my model.
I created the
Tasks model before.
So it will already
highlight that.
I can create this
table now here.
And what is really nice,
it's true data binding.
Because it knows
it's a Task model,
it will automatically create
all the columns for me
in the create.
So it knows exactly, like,
oh, you need a task name.
And that's the string.
So we sort it in
alphabetical order,
while the date needs to
be sorted on the date.
It's possible also
to enable paging.
They are all just
options that you see here
on the Options screen.
What I'm doing here is
I just do some resizing.
I position the grid
nicely on the screen.
I'll just put it in the top.
And I also give it a nice width.
I want to make sure that
this one runs on the form.
And I knew that I was
testing it on a laptop.
After I'm done with that, I
will drag another component
on the stage.
And in this case,
it will be a form.
I'm going to create an
Edit form or a Read form.
So every time, when
you select a task,
then it will show
that in this form.
And again, it
recognized the model.
So I said, OK, take the Task
model, true data binding.
Every time, when
I select the task,
you'll see the task
in the Edit screen.
And yeah, it does that
for me out of the box.
So I just dragged that
form on the stage.
Again, I will do some
resizing to make sure
that it's nicely aligned.
And after I'm done with that,
I will create an Add button,
so that I can open the pop-up
screen to add new components.
So I drag a button there.
And now, when I select
it, I can give it a name.
This is the name
of the button, if I
want to refer to it in code.
And I give it a text.
So then you see how it
looks like on the screen.
Yep, that went a bit fast.
And once I'm done with that, you
can click on Click menu here.
And then you say, like, OK, what
will happen when I select it?
Oh, in this case, I will
open the Add screen.
And then, yeah, you can
design the Add screen there.
It looks like I'm
missing a minute.
So I'll talk you through.
So after you design
the Add screen as well,
you can hit the Preview button.
That is what I did here.
And now you see the application
running in the browser.
I can create a task.
This is the pop-up.
I gave it just a title, just
from data, and a task date.
You see, you get a
nice date component.
I submit it.
And once it's there,
I can select it.
And then I can also
flag it as completed.
And once I completed it,
you see that it is also
completed in the top.
All right.
OK, so what you've seen is I
didn't use any coding here.
I was just dragging
and dropping.
But if I wanted to
make it more advanced,
I could use some coding.
You just need some JavaScript
knowledge for that.
That can be JavaScript on
the client, in the browser.
So then you just write
normal JavaScript code.
Or it can be App script code.
But you add that code in
the Apps script itself.
And automatically, you make
use of all the Google APIs,
and you can start
playing around with that.
So App Maker will
be available in Q4.
If you want, you can start
playing around with it.
You need to be a G
Suite business customer.
You can go to this page and
you can write this yourself.
So you can start
playing around with it.
I definitely would advise
you to play around with it,
because it's so easy to create
an application nowadays.
And with that, I'd like to
hand it over to Leo Koster,
from VOGSY, who has a
business application created.
And he likes to talk about that.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEO KOSTER: Thank you, Lee.
Hi, I'm Leo Koster.
I own an enterprise
software company
that is successful in
business since 1987.
And we were one of
the first in Holland
to be available on the
internet, online, in 2001.
But I wasn't happy.
Some three years ago, I
realized that we were not
moving fast enough, not
innovating hard enough,
not preparing ourselves
for future challenges.
And I asked myself,
what is happening?
The world is changing.
And software is
eating the world.
It's about new customers asking
me questions I couldn't answer.
And I saw a new
type of employees
coming that were
switching from software
their boss taught them to use
to software they love using.
And that became our new
mission, to create software
for the business
user that they love.
And to be able to
deliver on that promise,
we had to create something
completely new, from scratch.
And that is VOGSY.
VOGSY solves one problem.
Let me give you an example.
You're an IT services company.
And you're successful.
And you're growing.
The first thing
you put into place
is something on the back
end for a financial solution
to take care of your invoicing
and cache collection.
And then you go over to
putting something into place
to attract customers
and keep them--
outbound-inbound marketing.
But in the middle, it's chaos.
It's a combination of different
apps, custom solutions, paper,
you name it.
VOGSY turns this into a
smooth and efficient process.
Why business apps?
Let me introduce to
you Willem, Willem
[? Loesch, ?] founder and CEO of
one of our launching customers.
Willem's job is to produce one
of Holland's most famous export
products--
parties.
They started out by producing
the shows of DJ Chesto.
Now, they're producing big
corporate events worldwide.
And with every event, they
produce tons of information--
project planning, resource
planning, rigging planning,
sound planning, light planning,
sketches, detailed schemas--
massive amounts of data.
And they share this with
hundreds of people--
temporary employees, customers,
contractors, subcontractors--
everybody.
Everybody is connected
and working together,
collaborating on G Suite.
And G Suite enabled Willem
to grow even further.
But Willem was
missing something.
Willem came to us
with a question.
Why can't I find a
business app that
is integrating all
that information
from G Suite into something
I can look at at my phone?
Why?
Because when Willem is
producing his events worldwide,
this is his office, a taxi--
and in this case,
a taxi in Tokyo.
The backseat of the
taxi is his office.
And he wants to be able
to sit there and have
a look at his phone and to
see whether his projects are
on track, his people productive,
his invoices going out,
and the money coming in.
And of course, we told
him, look no further.
We have VOGSY.
What is VOGSY?
VOGSY is a vertical solution
for a very specific market.
It's for professional services.
It's for everybody who
is delivering services
through projects with
highly-skilled professionals
on the move.
What sets VOGSY apart--
that's three things.
The first one-- it's a
social user experience.
We've taken the best
examples of social media
to the business space.
We've taken the timeline the
activity stream to the business
user.
And how's that helping?
Because then nobody has to ask
anymore, where can I find it?
--the most commonly asked
question with business users.
And we have an avatar with
VOGSY-- that's Victor--
who's helping you
through the day.
Mobile first-- that's obvious.
Because in a couple
of years, there
won't be any more mobile first.
It will be mobile only.
And the third one
is a no-brainer,
because Google Cloud will
be the dominant platform
with next generations.
Who is using VOGSY?
The account manager responsible
for the customer, the project
manager responsible for the
projects, the professional,
the engineer,
consultant, developer
doing the actual job, the
manager, and the support
staff in the back office.
And how are they
working together
in this quote to cash process?
It goes like that.
It starts with the account
manager creating the quote.
Then it goes through
the organization.
And it's a pretty
straightforward process.
It's expensive-- in the
purchase invoices going out.
And oh, let me go back.
Oop, I'm too fast here.
And then, if you do this
a multitude of times, then
perhaps it can be handy
to have a manager around
to have some overview.
And the crucial thing
here is the handovers.
I need to have my information
at exactly the right time
to do my job.
It's the handover between all
those personas, those roles
in professional services.
And VOGSY turns this
into a smooth, speedy,
and efficient process.
And how did we do that?
How did we develop VOGSY?
When we knew we had
to start from scratch,
I started looking at what
other successful software
companies were doing.
And they were making use of
other people's hard work.
They were using platforms,
platforms as a surface.
And I made an inventory of
all the available platforms.
And for me, the most
innovative, the most fun,
the most technologically
advanced,
was the Google Cloud platform.
And it gave me all
the possibilities
to create something beautiful.
And we formulated
some starting points--
do as little as possible.
Use what is
available, because you
want to be able to put a
minimum viable product out
on the market with as little
effort as possible and as soon
as possible.
Use everything by Google,
managed by Google.
We are developers.
So even DevOps is
difficult for us.
We want to develop no ops.
Oh, sorry.
Let's go back.
Building something new
for this connected world
makes only sense if you
have a global ambition.
So skill is important.
Design for scalability.
And for the business
user, security
is of paramount importance.
And with Google Cloud
Platform and working together
with G Suite, we
get that security.
Being on the Google
Cloud Platform
allows us to have a very
clean and simple architecture.
And we love clean and simple.
We have Angular on the front
end, Python on the back end,
all managed by
Google on App Engine.
And the data is stored
in the Cloud Datastore--
nothing more.
Simple.
And in our pursuit of no ops, we
use some other Google products.
Our continuous deployment
is fully automated.
With Jenkins on
Compute Engine, we
monitor VOGSY by using Google
Analytics and the combination
of Stackdriver and BigQuery.
And we slice and
dice the information
with streaming the
data to BigQuery
and analyzing it
with Data Studio.
Here are some examples of
the integration with G Suite.
The first one-- it's
user management,
identity management.
Every user, especially
the business user,
hates logging on,
signing in, especially
if they have to sign in
to different applications
to complete one job.
And we've taken care of that
by using the Google account.
It's a matter of signing in,
choose the right account,
and you're done.
Another example is storing data.
Everybody knows
how difficult it is
to get users to store the
data with the right projects,
right customers,
right opportunities.
We provide them with this little
icon, this little button here.
And you click it and you go
exactly to the right folder,
all managed through
the right APIs.
Everybody knows that
account managers
love to copy old quotes and
edit them-- copy and paste.
And I'm not going into
details about all the problems
that it's creating.
So we've made it easy for
them to just click one button,
create a new quote.
And it is created with the right
template, the right settings,
in the right folder, and is
ready there for them to edit.
This is one of my favorites--
sending out the quote.
I get notified on my
timeline that it's time
for me to send out this quote.
Somebody else approved it.
I click on the button.
And it's gone.
Entering data-- also
some fun points.
Nobody likes to
enter data any more.
And why should you?
You're on Google.
So you have to find information.
Here, I'm creating
a new organization
with a contact person.
I am looking up the
right organization
through the Google Places API.
Select it.
Select the right contact,
through a plus API.
And when I've entered
them, the result
is a cart filled with
the contact information,
the right pictures, logos.
I'm done.
Management and support staff--
they love Sheets for reporting.
So we created a bunch
of sheets for them.
And here you have a
financial example.
And table, Sheets, easy to use.
And we've developed their
own add-on with Apps Script
to refresh the data
into that report.
And last but not
least, installing VOGSY
through G Suite Marketplace--
we're using that
API to get VOGSY--
oh, sorry, let me get it back--
to get VOGSY into
your own domain
with all the right settings
for the right users.
That was the last example.
Curious about VOGSY?
We have a booth there
in the main hall.
If you have any
questions, please ask us.
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you, Leo.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Leo.
It's pretty impressive,
that application.
So definitely visit
the VOGSY booth.
So now you have seen there
are various ways in how
you can create applications.
Hey, you can do that
through App script.
You can do that with
your own codebase
and just integrate the
Google APIs inside of that.
Or you can App Maker.
And with that, I would like
to thank you for being here
and wish you a very great day.
And I don't want to
keep you up from lunch.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]